mia tu m'a emmené si loin sans jamais me
quitter
c'est grâce à toi si j'en suis là
aujourd'hui à cet endroit sur terre et à
cet endroit dans ma vie pourtant tu m'as
dévorer à tous me prendre je ne vivais
plus que pour toi et je voulais plus
vivre en tout cas vu comme ça c'est
marrant comme ce genre de choses arrive
toujours aux autres jusqu'au jour où
l'autre bas c'est toi tu sais bien
j'ai longtemps cru quand ignorants
n'existerait plus mais je sais que tu
seras toujours là cependant c'est plus
un désastre pour moi je ne pleure plus
quand je me regarde dans le miroir je ne
conclus chaque calorie que je mange non
j'ai réappris à vivre et même si parfois
je reprend le dessus
je sais désormais que tu ne me définit
plus que je suis bien plus que
boulimique anorexique
en découvrant le monde de l'audiovisuel
j'ai plongé dans mon propre reflet je me
suis enfermé dans cette belle image que
j'avais peintes ou plutôt que j'avais
tissés et dans laquelle je me suis
emprisonné emprisonné au point où je me
couper de toute réalité
dans ma tête c'était obsessions
alimentaires obsessions alimentaires
obsessions alimentaires et bah c'est pas
une vie ça c'est vraiment pas une vie ma
mère me portait à bout de bras et un
moment je me suis dit fuir ou mourir
alors un jour j'ai fui je me sentais si
vide
et pourtant j'avais tout j'ai hâte
ri à colombo au sri lanka le 8 mars 2018
quelques mois seulement après être
arrivée en finale de the voice avoir
déménagé à paris avoir rompu avec mon
petit ami avoir signé un contrat chez
universal et avoir participé à
l'eurovision alors que ça me plaisait
pas du tout mais surtout que quelques
temps seulement après avoir enfin mis
les mots sur toi boulimie wigna mien on
est resté au sri lanka seulement
quelques jours mais ça a changé ma vie
vraiment j'ai fait des rencontres qui
m'ont apporté une perspective totalement
différentes qui m'ont permis de me
sortir de ce monde artificiel dans
lequel j'étais j'ai appris que mercy se
dit avec la main sur le coeur
ensuite j'ai amorcé un travail
psychologique et je sais qu'aujourd'hui
encore c'est un peu difficile de se dire
je vais chez le psy c'est encore un peu
tabou mais c'est vraiment pas une honte
parce que ça m'a sauvé la vie
j'ai aussi repris mes études à la
sorbonne en lettres ce que j'adore ça
j'ai dit à mon label
j'ai besoin de temps laissez moi le
prendre ou laissez moi partir
marc construction a duré deux ans vous
direz c'est beaucoup deux ans mais c'est
rien pendant ces deux ans j'ai eu le
temps de me poser des question j'ai eu
le temps de faire des rechutes mais j'ai
réappris à vivre et j'ai décidé de faire
confiance à la vie alors c'est clair
j'ai perdu dix mille follower sur
instagram
bon mon manager a décidé de plus
travailler avec moi bon mais j'ai réussi
mes examens à la sorbonne
j'ai renoué le contact avec mon label la
confiance aussi et on a tourné un
premier clip
je suis fier de vous annoncer que mon
premier projet s'en rend janvier
j'ai aussi été choisi pour faire la
bande originale du film d'animation de
notre enfance sansom connaissez le plus
petit des grands héros tu aimes ruse la
chose la plus importante que j'ai
compris pendant ce parcours c'est
pourquoi je veux être chanteuse c'est
pas pour être belle à la télé c'est pas
pour avoir des like sur mes photos
non si pour partager mon univers c'est
pour être la voix de ceux qui n'ont pas
encore trouvé la leur c'est pour
peut-être pouvoir donner un message
d'espoir à ceux qui ont peur de ne pas
se réveiller demain parce que mia est
encore trop oppressante trop lourde
si lucide 2017 me vois j'aimerais lui
dire que c'est pas grave d'avoir cru
qu'elle devait être parfaite belle pour
ne pas être rejetés qu'elle devait être
maigre pour être aimé non si lucide de
2017 me voit et c'est ce qu'ils ont
connu
lucie de 2017 mais moi j'aimerais aussi
lui dire qu'elle va rencontrer pendant
son parcours des personnes qui verront
au delà de son apparence gilles heymes
gros pour plus que ce qu'elle représente
jeudi
aussi et finalement qu'elle s'en sortira
la transition vers l'âge adulte c'est un
moment difficile et je pense que
certains d'entre nous le vivent encore
aujourd'hui c'est pas facile de quitter
les parents pour découvrir le monde des
adultes mais elle s'en sortira et comme
tous ces hommes
toutes ces femmes qui ont survécu aux
troubles du comportement alimentaire
un jour elle aussi alors à la force de
monter sur la scène d'un ted talk et de
dire l'important c'est de prendre le
temps ce n'est pas de plonger peut-être
la première dans le courant même si on
se dit aussi je plonge pas maintenant ce
sera trop tard
à 17 ans c'est trop tard à 20 ans c'est
trop tard à 50 ans même si jamais trop
tard c'est ok de se mettre sur le bord
de la rive
le temps de reprendre des forces comme
ça le jour où on est prêt
on va pas suivre l'undd évidente du
courant et on va savoir nager dans
l'autre sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
semyon varlamov
il ya trois ans
expo
[Musique]
eh ouais
ça
[Musique]
cadets
puis
hanovre main
body
demain
est-ce qui
[Musique]
bonnet
ça y est puis
[Musique]
c'est peu
j c
[Musique]
ok
m
le mouvement comme ayem goodbody à l'ogc
nice
aie aie
[Musique]
dalleau
quinn
ap
alors
ihome odeur à un quiz
[Applaudissements]